انا برايي الشخصي انه ممكن يكون في اعمار
يعني لازم يصير اعماره ما تخلي حدا بخيمه
ثمان سنوات لا يمكن يكون حياه طبيعيه
ما في مانع انك تعمر وبعدين صاحب اللي
قاعد بالخيمه ترجعه على بيته ما في مش مش
معناها اذا انا قبلت اني ببيت اني انا
بسقد حقي اني ارجع على بيتي وهذا الشيء
شفنا مع الفلسطينيين يعني
[موسيقى]
حجمه طاقه المنبعثه من الزلزال يعادل 500
قنبله نوويه هكذا وصف مسؤول باداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه الدمار الواسعه
في بلاده وحتى في سوريا المجاوره هذا
الدمار يحتاج الى تقييم ودراسه قبل
الانطلاق في عمليه معقده تتطلب تخطيطا
ووقتا ومالا وجهدا عمليه تسمى باعاده
الاعمار اعمار ما دمره الزلزال فما حجم
الاضرار في البنى التحتيه في كل من تركيا
وسوريا وكيف الطريق الى اعاده اعماري ما
دمره الزلزال مرحبا بكم متابعينا في هذه
الحلقه من بودكاست بعد امس وارحب بضيف
الدكتور سلطان بركات استاذ السياسات
العامه بجامعه حمد بن خليفه في قطر
والمدير المؤسس للمعهد العالمي للدراسات
استراتيجيه في مؤسسه قطر دكتور بركات اهلا
بك الى حد الان كيف تقيم حجم الاضرار في
البناء التحتيه في تركيا وسوريا
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه هو في الواقع
طالما انه لسه فتره الزمنيه قصيره لا يوجد
عند اي احد تقييم حقيقي لحجم الاضرار لانه
ما في اي حدا كان عندهم امكانيه انه يعمل
هذا التقييم يعمل هذه الدراسات انما هناك
يعني تكهنات في حجم بعد هذه الاضرار وهاي
التكهنات تعتمد على
مبادئ اساسيه انه هناك
الاضرار للبيئه للبيئه المبنيه
الرئيسيه التحتيه في البلد وهاي يعني يمكن
اسهل شيء في لدار انه تحاول تحكي قديش
ثمنها لانهم بيعرفوا بشكل عام تكلفتها من
البدايه لكن الاضرار الاخرى الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه النفسيه اللي حصلت في هذا
المجتمع لسه ستاخذ اشهر قبل ما يتم تحديد
قيمتها الماديه وكيف ممكن يتعافوا
طيب يعني هناك كما قلت هذه الاضرار الان
التقديرات الموجوده هي بالاحرى كلفه ما
بناء هذه الابنيه التي تدمرت ولكن هناك
ارضيه جيولوجيه على خط زلازل هل هذا
الدمار الذي شهدناه
يدل على حاجه
واعاده نظر في البناء التحتيه في هذه
المنطقه طبعا هو اول نقاش رايحين يدخلوا
فيه هو عمليه اعاده الاعمار هل نعيد
الاعمار على ما كان عليه او نستفيد من هذه
الفرصه حتى يعيد الاعمار بشكل افضل
والافضل هنا انه يكون في عندك حمايه من
الزلازل القادمه ان الكل بعرف انه هاي
المنطقه الزلزاليه ستستمر في كونها منطقه
حساسه ومعرضه للزلازل
تكلفه البناء بشكل اساسي ستضعف لانه الكل
راح يفكر كيف نبني بشكل افضل واقوى
ويتعامل مع الزلازل كلها القصص
حجم البناء ومساحه البناء ايضا ستختلف
راح يعيد النظر في المباني عاليه الارتفاع
يحاول انه يكون الامتداد افقي بشكل اكبر
حتى الطرق الطرق الضيقه اللي ادت الى انه
كان عمليه الانقاذ صعبه
تحرير الضحايا الى اخره الان سيتكلموا عن
طرق تكون اوسع المسافه بين المباني تكون
اكبر بحيث سقطت مبنى ما يؤثر على اللي
جنبه ولا اخره ففي هناك مبادئ للتخطيط في
المناطق الزلزاليه هي كان المفروض انه
اخذينها بعين الاعتبار من اول وتركيا
عندها خبره طويله في الزلازل وفي الحقيقه
هو حكومه اردوغان دخلت قوانين بالتسعينات
للتعامل مع الزلازل والبناء في هذه
المناطق لكن للاسف لم يلتزم بها الناس
ولم يلتزم بها رؤوس الاموال اصحاب رؤوس
الاموال ولا الحكومه طبعا ما شيكت وما
تابعت
والاسباب لهذا الموضوع انا برايي يعني
اصلها اقتصادي برجع لتكلفه البناء يعني
هلا تركيا خلال
عشرين سنه الماضيه مرت في كذا في اكثر من
ازمه يعني بس الثمان سنوات الماضيه والست
سنوات الماضيه كان في عندهم ازمه الانقلاب
وبعدين جاها الازمه الاقتصاديه وعندك
الحرب بسوريا واللاجئين جايين من سوريا
لهاي المناطق وبعدين صار في عنا ازمه
الكورونا والى اخره كلهم بيطلعوا لايوكرين
فكل هذا من الناس صارت تحاول توفر في
تكلفه البناء والضغط الموجود على الناحيه
سكانيه مع قدوم اللاجئين من سوريا ادى
لانه الماركت بده السوق بده يحاول يعوض
النقص فهذا انا بتقديري لو المباني اللي
بنشوفها المباني الحديثه اللي عماله بتوقع
كل عمرها سبعه ثمانيه سنين يعني في كثير
اشياء في مباني قديمه تاريخيه
عمرها مئات السنين وصمدت امام هذا الدمار
الواسع في البنيه التحتيه لا سيما في
تركيا بما انه يعني فعليا المثال الذي
نستطيع ان التفكير به والتخطيط له هو
تركيا من اين تبدا عمليه اعاده الاعمار في
المناطق المنكوبه
هلا هو في في هاي الحالات اول اسبوعين
بالعاده هو
البحث والانقاذ وهذا يختلف عليه كمان بعض
الخبره في ناس بقول لك لا اسبوع وبعدين
لازم تبدا تفكر باعاده الاعمار لكن في
الحقيقه هو بده اسبوعين وزي ما احنا
شايفين لسه في امكانيه انه يطلعوا ناس
احياء لانه كل مبنى الى خصوصيته ما بتعرف
انت في مباني ممكن عملت جيوب هوائيه
داخلها نتيجه الدمار وفي عندك ناس لسه تحت
الانقاذ فهذا المرحله خلال هاي المرحله
بالعاده ببدوا الناس يفكروا بالتخطيط
لاعاده الاعمار
الخطوه عمليه التانيه هي ازاله
الردم او الدمار اللي حصل
وتنظيف هذه المناطق وهذا بعتمد كثير على
البعد الثقافي والموجود عند الناس يعني
هلا احنا نعتقد انه كثير من الجثث موجوده
في ما بين هذه الانقاذ فبالتالي انت ما
بتقدر انك فقط
تشيلها كلها بشكل سريع وتكبها بدك تحاول
كمان تمشي شوي شوي اذا بتقدر انك تتعرف
على الاشخاص تتعرف اذا ما بتعرف تتعرف
احنا بنصل عليهم صلاه الغائب ولا اخره
يعني قصص انه لازم تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
ازاله الانقاذ لوحدها ممكن تاخذ لها ست
سبعه اشهر التنظيف الانقاذ وبعدين بدك
تفكر تزيلها الى اين في بعض المدن وبعض
الخبرات الى خارج البلد المدينه اللي كانت
دمرت وفي هلا التوجهات حديثه انه لا
يقوموا باعاده تدوير هذه الانقاذ
بجيبوا الالات والماكينات وبحاولوا ما
تبقى من المباني الى ماده تستخدم لردم
الشوارع
احنا حسناء
في في هلا توجهات في خبرات بالاخص لاعاده
تحويل واستخدام الحديد الحديد ماده غاليه
وصعب انك تجيبها بسهوله لكن في امكانيه
انك تعيد تدويرها من هذا انقاذ والناس
اللي او الخبراء اللي تكلموا عن اعاده
تدوير
الانقاذ في الموقع بعتبروا انه في هناك
يعني نوع من توفير الطاقه وتوفير الجهد
والمال انك
استخدامها يعني ما افهمه الان اساسا
تكنولوجيا اكثر تطورا من بدايه الالفين
حين كان هناك اقرار بقوانين جديده تبعت
زلزال 99 فهل بالتالي سنشهد قوانين جديده
في تركيا حول شروط الاعمار واعاده الاعمار
في مناطق الزلازل هل هي ستكون مبنيه اكثر
على محاسبه اعلى لمن يخالف هذه المعايير
ام مبنيه فعليا على تطور حدث في
التكنولوجيا
الاثنين هو التكنولوجيا لازم انها تكون
تؤخذ بين الاعتبار وتنعكس
بالقوانين لانه هو الكل بعرف انه هاي
المنطقه لا يمكن انك تحميها مئه بالمئه
حتى من ناحيه تقنيه هم لما يصمموا مبنى
ليتعامل مع الزلازل بياخذوا الابرج
بياخذوا معدل الزلزال وبالعاده مثلا
بصمموا لسته سته فاصله خمسه سبعه على اساس
انه هذا هو زلزال ممكن يتكرر اكثر ما حدا
بيقدر يصمم للزلزال زي اللي حصل مثلا
الدمار اللي احنا شفناه طريقه
المباني كيف وقعت القوه اذا بدك تاخد
تصميم على هذا الاساس راح يكون كتير صعب
فهما بياخدوا على حسب الابراج التاريخي
لهذه المنطقه اذا صار عندك زلزال قوي اللي
هو ممكن يحصل مره في القرن لا حول ولا لكن
بالتصميم
اللي بياخد بيعملوه بحمي من مئات الزلازل
يعني هاي منطقه ضربتها كتير زلازل خلال
السنوات الماضيه ما حدا حاس فيها طيب
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وعد
باسكان نصف مليون مواطن من الفئات الفقيره
والمتوسطه في غوطون عام كم التقديرات
بكلفه اعاده الاعمار بهذه السرعه
التقديرات انا ما بعرف لكن انا اعتقد انه
عمل غلطه مع احترامي له كشخص
بعملها كل رئيس يبحث عن عن ناخب يعني هدول
هذه عباره كتير نسمعها بعد الزلازل
والمشاكل انه احنا راح نعيد اعمار لكل
واحد خلال سته اشهر الجواب لا يمكن انك
تعيد الاعمار خلال سته اشهر او سنه الا
اذا انت بدك تعطيهم مره ثانيه بيوت مؤقته
وانها تعطي بيوت مؤقته ولا تدخل في عمليه
الاماره حقيقيه معناك انت بدك تضاعف تكلفه
الاعمار لانه هاي البيوت المؤقته لن
تطول يعني من ناحيه الاستخدام والكل بعرف
انه هاي البيوت المؤقته اللي تركيا اصلا
بتصدر للعالم منها فيها مشاكل كثيره
حراريه للتعامل مع الجو ناحيه الخصوصيه
يعني اذا هذه اخذت البيت انت وانتقل من
مكاني لمكان وخرب معك مفصل واحد راح الباب
بدك ترجعي تجيبي استنى يجيك ثانيه
ويعني في تعقيدات معينه بتادي بالاخر انك
انت بتدفع الاعمار مرتين فهو اذا وعد بسته
اشهر مثلا على سبيل المثال يعني ما راح
اكرر عشره بليون بصرف اول عشره بليون
وبرجع بعدين بده يصرف اللي بعدها في
الحكومات الديمقراطيه بعتمد على دوره
الحكومه ولا انا بصرفهم خلال دورتي وناس
بتنبسط وبعدين اللي بعده بيجي بتحمل
مسؤوليه الاعمار الاطول مدى طبعا هو مش حل
حقيقي ولا حل يعني مستدين
وفي نقطه مهمه كمان بهاي المنطقه بعرفش
انحكى فيها اللي هي المباني التاريخيه هي
المنطقه مهمه جدا لتاريخ تركيا تاريخ
الاسلامي تاريخ المنطقه كلها
نشوء الدوله العثمانيه وانتشارها والمباني
الموجوده فيها غازي عنتاب في كثير منها
مباني نجاه لكن في منها مباني تاريخيه
سقطت وهاي لازمها علاج خاص انك انت لا
تستطيع انك تعيد اعمارها
باستخدام مواد الكمكيه ولا انك
تبدلها بشيء تاني يعني المبنى المسجد
التاريخي المفروض انه ينعاد عماره كمسجد
وبالتالي في عندك خطوات كمان مكلفه من
البدايه انها كيف تحافظ على ما تبقى منه
اولا كيف تمنع السرقه لانه الشيء كثير
للاسف يعني بيحصل في هذه الاوقات انه
بدخلوا ناس عصابات متخصصه بهذه المواضيع
وبالاخص المباني التاريخيه يعني انت عندك
الناجين يمكن يمد ايده على سوبر ماركت على
اكل على مي على مش عارف شو بيجي لكن
الاخطر وهذه الاشي لازم يكون بعبالهم
عصابات الاثار هدول بيجوا من اخر ما عمر
الله وبكون متخصصين يعني بيجيك باسم
الانقاذ
متخصص في انه ياخذ
الاثار يعني بيعرفوا بالضبط احنا بنقول
يعني بصروا على الكتالوج
فبيعرفوا ايش في المتاحف ايش في المباني
المهمه وهاي خلال المومعه اللي بتصير
والخضه اللي بتصير خلال اول ست اشهر كتير
امور ممكن انها تتسرب خارج البلد طيب
تحدثنا عن ان كلفه اعاده الاعمار اذا
كانوا سيلجاون لما باني مؤقته ستكلف الضعف
ولكن هناك حاجه ربما هل هناك حاجه اساسا
لتركيا لمساعدات خارجيه لاعاده الاعمار
وفي ظل الاقتصاد العالمي والركود العالمي
الى اي مدى يعني يمكن ان تساهم الدول
الاخرى مع تركيا فيها عمليه الاعمار هذه
طبعا زي ما حكينا تركي عماله بتدخل من
مازق الى مازق صار لها كذا سنافه في طبعا
حاجه للفلوس الحاجه للكاش لكن الحاجه
للمساكن انا بعتقد ممكن ياخذوا يعني موقف
اخر ويفكروا في احنا ما بدعم منسميه مرونه
المساكن الموجوده في اي بلد بتلاقي احنا
كتير في ناس عنا في منطقتنا عنده بيت
وعنده بيت صيفي
في عندك فنادق غير مسكونه في عندك مدارس
في المباني كثيره ممكن انه يستفيد منها
بشكل مؤقت قبل ما انه يتسرع باعطاء
المباني
مؤقته هاي اللي هي
سوريا سوريا الحرب والمشاكل السياسيه مع
النظام السوري
هل هناك اليه دوليه يمكن ان تتخطى كل هذه
العوائق
وتعمل على اعاده اعمار او على استجابه
سريعه ام سنبقى ضمن الاستجابه السريعه فقط
هي استجابه لكنها ليست سريعه ايضا استجابه
انسانيه
لا بدون حل سياسي صعب جدا ما ممكن اتخيل
ايش ممكن يصير يعني الدول اللي اللي تجرات
ودخلت الحدود يمكن قطر واحده منها هي دول
لها علاقه قويه جدا مع تركيا وهي هاي
المنطقه بشكل او باخر تحت السيطره التركيه
يعني بتنسيق مع الجماعات اللي ماسكتها من
احرار الشام الى اخره هدول المناطق
يعتبروا لا زالوا يعتبروا تحت السياده في
دمشق وحسب القانون الدولي يعني ما حدا
مستعد يدخل مع انه فعلا بالحقيقه وفي
قانون
يسمح بالتدخل اذا فشلت الدوله
بحمايه مواطنيها وهذا هو عرف يعني موجود
واستخدم قبل هيك في ليبيا استخدم في
البوسنه استخدم في الكوسوفي
المناطق اخرى لكن الوضع اللي احنا فيه
للاسف انه حتى يتم استخدام هذا هذه الاداه
يجب يكون هناك في اتفاق على مجلس الامن ان
روسيا اذا رجع هناك روسيا راح توقفوا
وتمنعه
الطريق الوحيد انا اعتقد انه يستخدم او
يستخدمه الزلزال والماساه هاي يحطوا ضغط
نفسي وضغط يمكن ادبي على دمشق اذا كان هذا
ممكن انك انت ترجع تشوف معهم مره ثانيه
اذا انت بتقول هاي المنطقه تحت سيادتك
وتعال ورجينا جيب ايش في عندك عماره ايش
في عندك قصص بتقدر تساعد فيها وهاي
مسؤوليه الحكومه بشكل اساسي حتى الامم
المتحده مشكلتها
طريقه التعامل المؤسساتها تتعامل مع
الدوله اللي هي سوريا ما تتعامل معها
المحتاجين فمفروض انه يكون في هناك ضغط
اكبر والعالم بعتقد لو في
الويل او
النيه بيقدر يعملها مثلا نوع على
افغانستان على الطالبان حشروهم عملوا
عليهم مقاطعه عملوا عليهم ضغوطات بيقدروا
يطلع بيدهم اشي فممكن نفس الشيء يعملوا مع
سوريا لكن الخوف عندهم هو
انه يتكرر اللجوء لاوروبا ثم معتبرين انه
هذه الزون اللي في شمال سوريا حماه اوروبا
من كمان اربع مليون بني ادم يحاول يطلع
على اوروبا فبقول لك لا خليها عندكم احسن
ما يجوا عندنا
وفي هيك يعني ترتيبات تحت الطاوله انا
بعتقد
ادت الى ان الوضع الموجود الان يستمر بدون
ما يكون في محاسبه حل سياسي كيف يمكن في
الشمال السوري حل سياسي يؤدي الى بناء
مؤسسات او يعني ضمن اي منطقه اساسا تنتهي
شمال سوريا بوجود مؤسسات دوله يمكن فعليا
ان تبني ما بعد الحرب وما بعد الزلزال
الان بما انه هناك كارثتين
طبعا حل سياسي هو الاساس لكن
ما اعتقد في نيه زي ما حكيت
والطريقه المجتمع الدولي وصل
نقطه انه ارتاح نفسيا بخلق ادلب ادلب
لمه الناس ما في هجره وما في موت يومي زي
ما كان قبل لكن في قنبله موقوته انا بعتقد
انه حتى الناس الموجوده هناك بغض النظر عن
كل مواضيع الارهاب ولهذا الضغط النفسي
والاجتماعي الموجود على الشباب انا
المخيمات اللي شفتهم
والمشاكل الموجوده على مستوى المخيم كافيه
انها تطلع يعني جيل
يعني
بخوف والله يعني يحميهم ويحمينا من ايش
ممكن يطلع منهم لانه يعني اساسيات الحياه
وكرامه انك يكون في كرامه وفي محمي بين
اهلك مش موجوده على مستوى
الخصوصيه
السيدات في دول المخيمات لازم تروح على
المرحاض مره باليوم متى تروح مرتين ثلاثه
ولما تروح بدها تاخذ
يعني يحافظوا على خصوصيتها فهذه قتلت ما
تبقى من اعتقد روحها دجيله في شباب صغار
للي تركوا هناك قبل
ست سنوات صاروا شباب يعني تركوا اولاد
وبنات لو صاروا بالعشرينات لا في شغل لا
في
مجتمع مدني ما في شيء ما في شيء فهدول
الحل انه
لازم يصير في حل سياسي ولازم مجتمع الدولي
ياخذ مسؤوليته معهم اما المرحله اللي هم
وصلوا لهلا انه الكل مرتاح ما في شيء بكره
اذا لازم محلها صار في حركات ارهابيه وطلع
اشي برجع بتذكروهم بس لما يتذكرهم يا
بخصفوهم
وبحاولوا انهم يقضوا عليهم او راح يرجعوا
له انتم هيك شعب كعلم عربي ما في منكم
فائده لازم ارهابيين يعني ابا عن جد لكن
هي الحقيقه هو التقصير اللي صار بالحل
السياسي التقصير اللي صار بالناحيه
الانسانيه حتى حتى باعاده الاعمار انا
برايي الشخصي انه ممكن يكون في اعمار يعني
لازم يصير عماره ما تخلي حدا بخيمه ثمان
سنوات لا يمكن يكون حياه طبيعيه
ما في مانع انك تعمر وبعدين صاحب اللي
قاعد بالخدمه ترجعه على بيته ما في مش مش
معناه اذا انا قبلتني اني انا بسقط حقي
اني ارجع على بيتي وهذا الشيء شفناه مع
الفلسطينيين يعني واللي صار بالفرق ما بين
الفلسطينيه اللي حطوهم بلبنان
والفلسطينيين طلعوا على الاردن
كونك قلت انك تعيش بمستوى احسن
لا يعني انك انت تنازلت عن حقق في العوده
طب تحدثنا في البدايه عن انه الزلزال يمكن
ان يكون فرصه في تركيا لاعاده اعمار وفق
اسس جديده اكثر مقاومه للزلازل مما تحدث
عنه عن ماساويه الوضع في سوريا قبل
الزلزال اساسا وهذا التخلي والخذلان قبل
الزلزال باعوام
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يكون الزلزال فرصه او
كيف يمكننا ان نخلق فرصه للشمال السوري من
الزلزال لاعاده التذكير اننا لا نحتاج
لداعش ولا نحتاج
لمعارك ولهجره لنذكر بضروره ايجاد حل دائم
لهؤلاء القابعين في خيم منذ 8 سنوات اول
شيء من
المقاومه السوريه
انا بعتقد انه يعني لازم يخدم مسؤوليتهم
كامله بهذا الموضوع والوضع اللي هلا قائم
انك انت يعني مقاومه في الخارج ومش واضح
بالزبط دورك في الداخل مشكل
اذا كان فعلا انت خلص وصلت الى قناعه انه
ما في امل انك تقاوم اكثر انا لازم يفكروا
في حل ويصير هناك تراجع بمنطقه او باخرى
بحيث انه ترجع لحضن الدوله وبنفس الوقت
اعتقد الدوله والضغط الدولي عليها انه راح
يكون لازم يكون انه انت بتاخدك دوله او ما
في دوله يعني هذه فكره انك انت لا لسه لك
السلطه والك هذه الفكره يعني
مر عليها الزمن واثبتت انه في قصبه وفي
اخره اذا انت مش قد المسؤوليه ما بتخدم
مسؤوليه خلاص لازمها انت تعطي مسؤوليه
واحد تاني
ممكن
يؤ حركه انفصال في ناس بتحكي على انه حتى
تركيا كان في عندها مخطط لضم هذه المناطق
ضمها بشكل يعني
مش شكل قانوني مئه بالمئه لكن تدريجي وهذا
الضم انتهى طريقه انك انت بتحميها اول
وبعدين بتصير انت مسؤول عنها اقتصاديا
بعدين
بيجوا بتعالجوا عندك وبعدين بيرجعوا عندك
على الجامعه وهذه الاشياء عم بيصير حاليا
فهي بالفعل صارت منطقه يعني قريبه لتركيا
ممكن المعرض تقول والله يا اخي احنا خلاص
احنا
مستعدين نجمع تركيا اذا انت ما بدك ايانا
بدمشق خلاص احنا بنروح مع تركيا
لكن للاسف قاعدين بالنص لا هم هيك ولا هم
هيك
بنضلنا نقاوم والان صارت بنضل نقاوم لاخر
سوري في هذه المنطقه وهلا جاهم الدمار
هادو لسه يعني الوضع ما اعتقد راح يتحسن
كتير يعني يمكن يصير فيه شوي
مساعدات حجما اكثر لكن النوعيه لن تختلف
رح يضل يعطوهم مساعدات انسانيه اعنيه
الناس بتاكلها وبعدين بتمر ما في اشي يعني
واستدام ويبني واقتصاد وصناعه وتعليم
وجامعات وكل القصص هاي اللي احنا بناخذها
نعتبرها اشياء اساسي في اي مكان اخر شكرا
لك دكتور سلطان بركات استاذه السياسات
العامه في جامعه حمد بن خليفه والمدير
المؤسس للمعهد العالمي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في مؤسسه قطر شكرا لك شكرا
لك كان هذا بعد امس
[موسيقى]